today we're talking about security the
latest from document ai and a
behind-the-scenes look at vmware engine
i'm debbie and welcome to this week in
cloud where we serve you the lowest
latency news
may was another big month for us as we
get ready for more industry work and
engagement at the rsa security
conference in san francisco
at our security summit and throughout
the past month we continued to launch
new security products and features and
increased service and support for all
our google cloud and google workspace
customers
check out our cso's perspective on these
announcements and more on the blog
the google cloud document ai solutions
have been designed to help solve some of
the hardest problems for data capture at
scale by extracting structured data from
unstructured documents reducing
processing costs and improving business
efficiency
with the recent ga release of document
ai for identity businesses can leverage
automation to extract information from
identity documents with a high degree of
accuracy without having to bear the cost
and turnaround time of manual tasks by a
service provider learn more on the blog
google cloud vmware engine allows a user
to deploy a managed vmware environment
within an enterprise cloud solution
we've put together a new whitepaper
google cloud vmware engine performance
migration and benchmarks to help our
customers better understand the
architecture its performance and the
benefits
if you're not familiar with google cloud
vmware engine yet head to the blog where
we'll talk a bit more about it
if you want to read more about these
announcements or see a full list check
out the link
any thoughts or ideas leave us a comment
or tweet us we'll see you in the cloud
you